welcome to the show it's great to be
back uh i know i'm tan please no emails
about me being tan i wore sunscreen i
did all of it um we had a lot of major
major news events during the period that
i was gone farron and jesse did a really
great job of staying on top of
everything for you and i want to start
today
with the most requested segment over the
last 72 hours which was people coming to
me and saying david sir
please tell us what you think about
what's going on in afghanistan now as
many of you who have been with the show
for a while may remember you may not but
you may that we'll find out soon
you might remember that i talked about
the afghanistan withdrawal when donald
trump planned to do it and announced
that he was doing it
and i talked about it again when joe
biden announced hey that pause we put on
trump's afghanistan withdrawal we've
evaluated it and we are going to do it
and it's going to happen by september
11th
president joe biden is now being widely
criticized for his actions in
afghanistan
which are carrying out the plan to
remove troops that donald trump and
republicans
bragged about and cheered for
for months during the end of donald
trump's presidency now that's not me
starting to say well i'm going to blame
here or there it's just the reality what
biden did was
to go forward with more or less the plan
that donald trump announced than that
trump cheered
and that trumpists cheered
predictably
just like we said a few months ago
whether it was trump leaving or biden
leaving it would cause chaos
but at a certain point our
responsibility has to end
because our involvement has been a
disaster staying longer won't solve
anything the afghanistan intervention
failed and it's really important in
these cases when people start saying oh
we left the wrong way or we did oh we
can talk about that
but at a certain point our involvement
had to end even though uh biden is
sending 6 000 troops back in now which
we'll get to uh and it was going to be a
fiasco whenever it ended those things
were essentially uh uh
they were certain regardless of which
president was in the oval office when
this happened so we could stay and keep
failing or we could leave the vacuum
when we left as was worldwide news
earlier this week
immediately led to the taliban taking
over
and then all sorts of different hot
takes joe biden left the wrong way
we do have to ensure the safety of our
people and to be empathetic when it
comes to refugees that
we i am on board by saying
there should have been better advance
uh action
to prevent some of what we saw
there
but unfortunately
a lot of it was essentially inevitable
as we said months ago
the same people
pro-trump republicans who now are
ignoring that donald trump had the same
plan
are starting to say this would have been
totally different if it had been managed
by a different president uh actually no
it wouldn't have been
and there are some trumpists as well as
people on the left who just don't like
joe biden who are now saying well the
vacuum allowed the taliban to take over
and we didn't do enough to get our
people
other people refugees out in time if we
had done the get people out in time part
you think those people would be
satisfied no those very same people
would just be focusing on the taliban
took over and we would be seeing the
exact same reactions from those people
and sadly there are tons of bad faith
actors on both sides on this issue now
i'm not saying
the same number of people on both sides
i would be called out for playing the
both sides game if i did that but there
are bad faith actors on both sides right
now you have people on the right saying
terrible decision by joe biden when
trump was going to do this
uh it was going to be totally different
no trump would have done it in the exact
same way don't let them lie and say
trump had some master plan for
preventing what happened trump had no
master plan for anything the idea that
he would he would have had such a plan
for afghanistan is absolutely absurd
trump would have done the exact same
thing and by the way
all the references to this being trump's
plan all along suddenly removed from the
gop website uh trump's websites within
hours of this going down in afghanistan
all of those references to trump's plan
to get out of afghanistan deal with the
taliban et cetera it's a bold-faced
attempt to revise history
then
the left saying this is the typical
centrist democrat foreign policy of joe
biden you go in for the wrong reasons
and then you cut and run well hold on a
second george w bush is responsible for
us being there not joe biden not donald
trump and not barack obama there is not
nearly enough discussion of george w
bush here and i think that you know if
you go to a bad dentist and the dentist
screws up your tooth
and then you go to other dentists and
the first dentist that tries to fix it
doesn't do a great job and then you go
to a third dentist and that dentist
basically gets you out of harm's way
you're not gonna have an abscess but the
tooth is gonna hurt for several months
we talk about what the third dentist
wasn't able to do we talk about how the
second dentist messed up the repair but
what started it was that first dentist
who messed up your tooth and there is
not nearly enough discussion to use a
dental analogy
of george w bush and the bush
administration's role here there's a lot
of biden versus trump stuff at some
point someone had to say
what george w bush started can go no
further
no more money into this
no more contractors getting rich the
contractor's mostly out of afghanistan
over recent months because the
withdrawal was coming
that with the contractors we've got to
stop that as well
uh and joe biden's speech to the nation
on monday it wasn't satisfying to a lot
of people who emailed me
but it was fundamentally an honest
speech and by honest i mean it's the
type of honesty we don't usually get
from politicians it was one of the most
honest political speeches by a president
in a long time and it was completely
decisive it was we had to do it
we had to do it as i tweeted earlier
this week quote so you stay another year
to leave correctly
simply delaying what happened by a year
enriching more contractors who would go
back in and so then what the same thing
happens in 2022
at some point you have to cut your
losses and joe biden's speech was
decisive and joe biden was the guy to do
it and he takes responsibility for what
took place after now if there's anything
to really criticize there it's well now
6 000 troops are going back in
to help people get out and restabilize
which we could say is going backwards
you pull out the last 1500
chaos ensues and you send the 6 000 back
in so i'm not saying
it's wrong to try to
help
grease the exit in some way i'm that
that's not my criticism but in in a
sense are we really even doing it if six
thousand are going back in well the
devil really is in the details with what
those six thousand are going to be doing
um and we will get back and we'll dig
into that further
probably later this week but you know
what it had to be done you don't tend to
see this level of decisive action uh on
foreign policy combined with just
telling it like it is
and so i think for that you have to give
biden credit and then we figure out
which aspects of it could have been
better managed
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five-star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 off and free shipping when you go
to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video